Herkese selamlar sevgili 9. sınıflar
nasılsınız bakalım? Umarım keyifler
yerinde her şey yolunda gidiyordur. Yine
enerjik bir giriş yapıyoruz. Konumuz ne?
14. derse geldik. Doğrusal
fonksiyonlarda eşitsizlik içeren
problemler çözeceğiz. Ya da bir diğer
eşitsizlikleri göreceğiz. Hani hem
doğrusal denklemler hem eşitsizlikler.
Yani bu konuyu işlerken şöyle olacaksın.
Hafif bir kekremsi tat gelecek ağzında.
Lan bu LGS konusu mu? 8. konusu mu diye
ufaktan düşüneceksin. Eee, birazcık
benziyor. Ben de zaten sana o bağlamları
hatırlata hatırlata ilerleyeceğim ve
böylece de eee, mevzuyu daha iyi
kavrayacağız. Neredeyiz? Tabii ki de
Moros Tuncuk'tayız. Yine kitabımızı
elimize aldık. 102. sayfadan başlıyoruz.
103 104 tokatlaya tokatlaya gidiyoruz.
Mükemmel sorularımız ve tabii ki de konu
anlatımımız var. Yeni Maarif Modele
uygun kitabı hala edinmediysem bence hiç
geç değil. Çünkü en sağlam konulardayız.
Hemen buradan başlayabilirsin. Yarı yıl
tatilinde de eksiklerini de
kapatabilirsin. Eğer hala edinmediysen
yeni marif modele uygun şöyle tuğladan
hallice kitabımızda kendini 9. sınıfta
çok iyi bir yere getirebilirsin.
Anlaştık dedim. Hatırlattım. İstersen
açıklama kısmında da eee linkini
bırakıyoruz. Oradan da bir
inceleyebilirsin. Tabii ki de kalan eee
sayfaları hemen sana ödev olarak eee
vereceğim. Sayfa 105'te, 106'da ve
107'de şahane sorularımız var. Yine
çözüm videoları var. Kare kodlarla
çözümlere de ulaşabileceksin. Hiç
problem yok. O zaman ne diyoruz? Abone
olmadıysan oluyoruz. Önce bir abone
olalım ki gerçek anlamda bir eee
desteğimizi gösterelim. Videoyu
beğenerek de yine bize desteklerinizi
gösterebilirsiniz. Yorumlarınızı
bekliyorum. Herkes hangi konuda? Ya
şöyle bir kargaşa var yorumlarda. Biri
diyor ki hocam çok hızlısınız. Bir başka
yorumda da görüyorum ki hocam biz daha
buralara gelmedik ki. Yani bir
ortalamayı alalım. Herkes an itibariyle
yorum yazdığı an itibariyle hangi konuda
olduğunu bir söylesin. Biz de hızımızı
ayarlayalım. O zaman ders ekranındayız.
Şimdi kendisini görüyorsunuz. Eee 16
kelimeden oluşan başlığımız doğrusal
fonksiyonlarla ifade edilebilen denklem
ve eşitsizlik içeren yani aslında
fonksiyonlarda denklem ve eşitsizlik
muhabbetine geçiyoruz bu ders ile
beraber.
Benden o zaman bu kadar giriş bu kadar.
2 dakikadır nefesim kesildi. Hadi o
zaman başlıyoruz. Hemen zoom'umu attım.
öğren diyerek başlıyoruz. Neyi
öğrenecekmişiz bakalım. Aslında bir
ufaktan eee ne diyelim? Hatırlatma gibi
de düşünebilirsin bunu. Şimdi en az biri
0dan farklı diyoruz. Kimlerin eee a ve c
gerçek sayılarından bahsediyoruz. Gerçek
sayılarda tanımlı f ve g
fonksiyonlarının cebirsel temsillerini
ne olarak düşünüyorduk gençler? fx = ax
+ b. Gx = cx + d olsun. Tamam. Buradan
elde edilen f(x) = g(x). Yani aslında
iki tane e cebirsel ifadeyi, cebirsel
temsili diyoruz artık listede 9. sınıfta
böyle kelimeler değişti. İki cebirsel
temsili eşitlediğimizde biz buna 1inci
dereceden bir bilinmeyenli denklem adını
vereceğiz. Yani aslında bildiğin denklem
ya x'lerin havalarda uçuştuğu denklem
muhabbeti. Peki denklem olayını anladık.
Hani ikisinin eşitliği varsa denklem ama
arada böyle küçüktür, küçük eşittir,
büyüktür ya da büyük eşittir gibi
ifadeler varsa da bu sembolleri
görüyorsan o zaman ne diyecektik? 1.ci
dereceden bir bilinmeyenli eşitsizlik
diyecektik. Yani denklem olması için
arada bir eşitlik olması gerekiyor.
Eşitsizlik olması için de arada
eşitsizlik sembollerinden biri olması
gerekiyor. Yani eşittir varsa denklem,
eşittir yoksa eşitsizlik diyoruz. Tamam.
Şimdi burada f(x) = g(x) denkleminden
biz bunları tek bir tarafa toplayıp 0
elde ediyoruz ya hani denklem nasıl
çözüyorduk? Herkesi diyorduk bir tarafa
salla salla salla salla. Bu şekilde
salladığında a - c yani x'in bak burada
neyi aslında? A - c dediğimiz olay x'in
başındaki arkadaşlar. İşte bunu cepte
tut. Bir de B - D var. Şu B - D de
aslında X'in yanında olmayanlar diyelim.
Buradan hareketle mx + n = 0 elde edilir
aslında. Yani şu hemen tarıyorum daha
net olsun. Bir saniye. Şu ifadeyi tamam
mı? Şu ifadeyi birazcık elini yüzünü
düzelttik. Ne yaptık? A - C'ye M dedik.
B - D şu kısma da N dedik aslında. Tamam
mı? Şimdi bu denklemde eş 0 yaptım.
Artık denklem çözümüne geçiyoruz. Burada
tabii ki de x'imiz bilinmeyen m ve
n'mizde katsayı, n ise sabit terim
olarak söyleyeceğiz. Tamam mı? Hani
katsayıdır sorarsam ne diyordun? M n.
Orada gördüğün sayılar diyorduk.
Hatırladık mı? Katsayı sorarsam sayıları
söyleyeceksin. Sabit terim sorarsam
başında daha doğrusu özür dilerim
yanında x olmayan ifadeyi söyleyeceğiz.
O da bizim sabit terimimiz. Şimdi eğer
şunu yapmaya kalkışırsan mx + n = 0
denkleminde x'i bulmaya kalkışırsan biz
o x'e ne diyoruz? Denklemin kökü
diyoruz. Denklemde x bulmak ne demek?
Aslında denklemin kökünü bulmak demek.
Ama karşında bir eşitsizlik varsa da
orada bulacağın x haliyle bir aralık
olacak. Mesela diyeceksin ki eksi
sonsuzdan 2'ye kadar falan. O zaman da
bu eşitsizliği sağlayan değerlerin
aralığına da ne diyoruz? eşitsizliğin
çözüm aralığı diyoruz. Laf da kalmasın.
Biz matematiği sorularla öğreniriz
hocam. Sorularımız geldi. Şimdi ufaktan
ısınma turları denklemin köklerini
bulacağız. Nasıl buluyoruz? E x'i yalnız
bırakacağız. -6'yı karşıya şutladığımda
ne olacak? x = 4 + 6 gelecek.
Dolayısıyla buradan ne bulacağım? 10.
Yani x = 10. Denklemin kökü 10
diyeceğim. Geçeceğim. 2incide + 3'ü
karşıya -3 olarak zıplattığımda ne
kalacak ortada? 2x = 12. E buradan da
bir tanesi 6 diyeceksin. Denklemin kökü
6'ymış diyeceğiz. 3üncüye baktım. + 4'ü
bu sefer zıplatalım karşıya. -4 geçsin.
Dolayısıyla -3x = 8 - 4'ten 4. Her iki
tarafı neye böleceğim? X'i yalnız
istiyorum. Başında -3 var. O zaman -3'e
böleceksin. Her iki tarafı -3'e bölersem
de 4/ -3 ya da şöyle eksiyi başa alıp
daha şık gözüksün. Bu şekilde de
yazabilirsin. -4/3. Denklemin kökü -4/3
diyeceğiz. İlerledim. Denklem biraz daha
sevimsiz gelirse karşımıza hocam ne
yapacağız? Gerekli işlemleri yapacaksın.
Tamam mı? Önce mesela 2'yi dağıtacaksın
bir parantez varsa. Yine bizim tablet
gitti. Hemen ayarlayalım. Kaldığımız
yerden devam ediyoruz. 2'yi dağıtıyorum.
Hemen buraya ne yazdım? 2 x x 2x + 2 x 3
6 = 8 e bu 1. soruya döndü. Bundan
sonrasını biliyorsun. 6'yı karşıya
tekmeledim. + 6 -6 geçti. Buradan da
bana ne kaldı? 2x 2 kaldı. Demek ki x
neymiş? 1'miş. Bak tertemiz denklemin
kökünü buldum. Sıradaki gelsin. Hemen
baktım -3'ü belli ki dağıtacağım. -3x
-3 ile +1'i çarptım. -3 = 2x. Şimdi
burada ne yapalım? Eksili kardeşlerimizi
karşıya zıplatalım ki artıya
dönüşsünler. Burada -3 yalnız kalsın. Bu
-3x'i
+ 3x attım. Yani sağ taraf etti bana 5x.
Bir tane x'i arıyorsam 5'e böleceğim.
Demek ki x'imiz -3/5'miş.
Yani denklemimizin kökü -3/5.
Geçtim sıradakine. Burada iyice kaosa
döndürdük. Yani ne varsa bütün
klavyedeki sayılara bastık. Dağıtacağız.
eksi ya da dağıtmayacağız. Vazgeçtim ya.
İlle de dağıt dağıt dağıt. Nereye kadar?
Şunu yapabilirsin. Her iki eşitliğin her
iki tarafında da çarpma durumunda
sayılarda sadeleştirme yapabiliyorsun.
Ne var burada? 2 var. 2'ye böldüm. 1
yani hatta pazara gönderdik. E -4'ü de
2'ye bölebilirim. Eşitliğin her iki
tarafını da aynı pozitif sayıya
bölebiliriz. Dolayı negatif sayıya da
bölebilirim bu arada. Hani eşittir
olduğu için eşitsizliklerde bir yön
değiştirme vardı. Bu da neyni yön
değiştirecek? eşittir zaten. Dolayısıyla
-4'ü 2'ye böldüm. -2. Şimdi ne
yapıyorum? Dağıtma işlemi yapıyorum.
Çarpmanın çıkarmaya dağılması. -2 ile
1'i çarptım. -2. -2 ile -x'i çarptım. +
2x e= sağ tarafta zaten katsayıyı pazara
göndermiştik. Bir etkisiz eleman yazma.
x + 4'ü direkt geçir. x + 4 yani 1 kere
x 1 kere 4 x + 4 yani. Şimdi olaya son
noktayı koyalım. Burada büyük abi 2x.
Burada bir tane x var. X'i sol tarafa
eksi gönderiyorum. Yani 2x'in yanına -x
geldi. Sağ tarafta ev sahibim 4. Bu
-2'yi de diğer tarafa 4'ün yanına + 2
geçirdim. 2x'ten x çıkarsa x kalır. Yani
bir tane x kaldı. 4 ile 2'yi topladım. 6
geçmiş olsun. Denklemin kökünü bulduk.
Şimdi iyice zıvanaadan çıkıyoruz.
Zıvana'dan çıktım. Buradaki denklemin
kökünü bulacağız. Rasyonelse ne
yapacağız hocam? Rasyonelse ne
yapıyordun? İçler dışları göm. Hemen ne
yapıyorum? 2 ile bunu çarpıyorum. X +
4'ü. İstersen bir adım da şöyle yazalım.
Hani ne yapacağımı yazayım önce. 2 ile x
+ 4'ü çarpacağım. 3 ile de x - 2'yi
çarpıp eşitleyeceğim. Yani ne yapıyorum?
Bunun adı ne? Matematikteki bu işlemin
adı içler dışlar çarpımı. Oğlum çok
melodik bir tanım aslında. Çok severiz
içler dışlar çarpımını. Bundan sonrası
çayda çıra dağıta dağıta yazacaksın. 2
ile x'i çarptın 2x + 2 x 4 8 = 3'ü
dağıtıyorum 3x 3 kere -2'den -6 ve
bundan sonra da artık 1. soruya
döndürdüm. Küçük kardeşimizi büyük
abisinin yanına gönderiyorum. 3x'in
yanına -2x geldi. Solda zaten 8'im var.
-6'yı da tekmeledin. + 6 geldi. 3x'ten
2x çıktı. Bir tane x kaldı. Laps diye de
x'i buluyorum bak. 8 + 6 14. Denklemin
kökü 14'müş. Geldim sıradakine. Heh.
Hadi hocam. Hadi burada da içler dışlar
yap diyemezler. Burada içler dışlar
yapamam. Dolayısıyla ne yapacağım? Payda
eşitleme. Niye içler dışlar yapamıyorsun
hocam? Çünkü burada bir toplama işlemi
var. İçler dışlar yapabilmem için direkt
her iki tarafta da birer rasyonel ifade
olması lazım ki çat çat hemen içler
dışlara başlayayım. Ama bir toplama
çıkarma muhabbeti varsa bak
rasyonellerin arasında bana şunu deme
hocam burada da çıkarma var. Hayır lan
öyle değil. Bu burada kusura bakmayın
biraz bazen yükseliyorum. Burada
rasyonellerin arasında bir toplama
çıkarma var. O yüzden içler dışlara
kalkışamıyoruz. Öyle bir operasyon
yapamayız ama payda eşitleriz. En büyük
kardeşimiz 8. O zaman bunu 2 ile
çarparım 8 olur. Bunu 4 ile çarparım 8
olur. Şimdi bütün paydaları aslında
eşitledim. Ne yapacağım? Üsttekilerle
paylarla olaya devam edeceğim. 2 ile x'i
çarptım 2x + Şimdi 4'ü çarpa çarpa
yazıyorum bak. 4x
- 4. Tamam. 1 diyenin kalemi kırılsın.
Sağ tarafta da payımız 1. Hocam
paydaları ne yaptın? Uçurdun mu?
Uçurdum. Hepsini pazara gönderdim. Sebep
çünkü paydalar eşit. Zaten rasyonellerde
biz payda niye eşitliyoruz? Paydayı
görmemek için. Zaten hepsi eşit
olduğundan dolayı sadece paylarla işlem
yapabilelim diye paydaları eşitleyip yok
ediyoruz. Sonracığıma 2x ile 4x toplandı
6x -4'ü karşıya + 4 zıplattım. 1 + 4'ten
orası da 5. Her iki tarafı 6 ile
tokatlarsam
x = 6'lar uçtu zaten. X yalnız kaldı.
Demek ki buradaki kökümüz de neymiş? 5/6
şiir gibi çözdük değil mi? Bence bir
edebiyat kitabından koparılmış sayfa
gibi. Şimdi abartı seviyem 4. soru ve
ufaktan eşitsizlik diyoruz. Şimdi basit
eşitsizlikler bunlar. 1inci dereceden
bir bilinmeyenli yani eşitsizlik çözümü
gibi düşünebilirsin. Ne yapacağız? -10'u
karşıya şutlayacağız. Aynı denklem çözer
gibi çözeceğiz. Bir farkı yok. Sadece
araya eşittir değil küçüktür koyuyorsun.
-10 karşıya geçti. + 10 oldu. Her iki
tarafı 2 ile tokatladım ki x'i yalnız
bırakayım. x< 10/2'den 5. Mevzu bu.
Çözüm aralığını soruyorsa burada
bırakmak ayıp olur. Tamam mı?
Matematiksel bir ayıp yaparız.
Dolayısıyla ne diyeceğiz? Aralık dediği
için Kasım deseydi farklı çözecektim ama
aralık dediği için böyle çözeceğim.
[kahkaha] Buradan buz kesti. Şimdi eksi
sonsuzdan
5'e kadar diyeceğim ve 5 dahil değil.
Aralık böyle gösterilir. Tamam. Geldim
B'ye. Şimdi burada ne halt yiyeceğiz?
Mevzu aynı. + 12 misin sen? Karşıya geç.
-12 ol. Burada 4x kaldı. 4x aradaki
işaretim eşit -12. Her iki tarafı x'i
yalnız bırakabilmek adına 4e bölüyorum.
Tak tuk 4leri pazara gönderdim. X <
-12'yi 4'e böl -3 buldum. Burada bak
kafan karışmasın. Eksiye bölme gibi bir
işlem yapmadığımdan dolayı eşitsizlik
yön değiştirmez. Eşitsizlik ne zaman yön
değiştiriyordu?
Her iki tarafı eksi ile çarpmada ya da
bölmede eşitsizlik yön değiştiriyordu.
Ama burada öyle bir şey yok. Şimdi tabii
bize aralık dediği için ne yapıyorsun?
küçük eşittir diyor. Yani x'ler -3'ten
de küçükmüş. Yani eksi sonsuzdan
geliyorlarmış bunlar. Tamam. Nereye
kadar? -3'e kadar. -3 kapalı aralık.
Çünkü dahiliyet var. -3 eşit küçük
eşitleri var ya. O yüzden köşeli
parantezle göstereceğiz. Geldim C
seçeneğine. Hemen -9'a vurduk. Tekmeyi.
Karşıya zıplattık. +9 geçti. Her iki
tarafı da 3 ile tokatladığımızda taktuk
x > 9/3'ten 3 buldum. Nasıl göstereceğim
şimdi? Bak x'ler 3'ten büyükmüş.
Aralığını bulacağız. Aralık şöyle 3'ten
başlayacağım. 3 dahil değil. O yüzden
normal parantez attım. Nereye kadar?
Sonsuza kadar. Sonsuz her zaman zaten
normal parantezle gösterilir. Şimdi bu
soruyu da tokatladık. Adcuk vitesi
arttıralım ve ne var? 5. sorudayız.
Hemen A seçeneğine baktım. Bu direkt
eksi ha kafa yanıltmasın. Kafa
yanıltmasın de ya bizi yanıltmasın.
Şimdi ne yapacağız? Denklem çözer gibi
bak. Eşitsizlik çözmek ekstra bir bilgi
gerektirmiyor aslında. %99. Dolayısıyla
hani ekstra gereken şey ne? Hani eksi
ile çarpma bölme yaparsan o zaman işin
yönü değişir muhabbetini unutmaman
lazım. Ama burada ben mümkün olduğu
kadar o işlere bulaşmayacağım ki
ekstraya girmeyelim. Tamam mı oğlum?
Ekstra su yakmıyoruz burada. Yani şimdi
tamam mı? 3 ile x'i çarptım. 3x 3 x -4
-12. Hemen -2'yi dağıtıyorum. -2x - 2 <
0. X'leri burada bir tutalım. Bunlar bir
birlesin. 3x - 2x'ten 1x kaldı. Aa laps
diye geldi elime. Hemen -12 karşıya + 12
zıpladı. -2 karşıya + 2 zıpladı. 12 2
daha 14. Aradaki işaret küçüktürdü. O
zaman x< 14. Yani ek sonsuzdan geliyorum
14'e kadar. Ama 14 dahil değil.
Tokatladık. Tertemiz. Patates ettik.
Geçtik. Şimdi burada her iki tarafı
dağıtacağım. Dağıtalım bakalım. 4x - 4 x
2 8. Arada bir yük eşit var. 2'yi
dağıtıyorum. 2x + 2 x 4 8. Tertemiz.
Şimdi kankalar buluşsun. 2x tekmeledin.
4x'in yanına eksi geçti. 2x kaldı.
Burada + 8 var. -8 hop + 8 geçti 8 16
Her iki tarafı 2'ye böldüm x > 8'i
buldum bir de aralık olarak yazalım.
Şimdi 8 dahil 8'den başlıyorum ama
büyükmüş. Artı sonsuza kadar gideceğim.
Anlaştık. Bu da tamam. Artık şu fmesi
gerekiyordu. 6. soru itibariyle bu işi
fonksiyonlara bulaştırıyoruz. Şimdi f ve
g fonksiyonlarımız r'den r'ye. Yani
diyor ki en geniş sayıları kümeni düşün.
Sıkıntı yok diyor. Herhangi bir yerde
bizi kısıtlamamış. Fonksiyonlar
verilmiş. Buna göre aşağıdaki sağlayan
en geniş çözüm aralıklarını cebirsel
temsil yönteminden faydalanarak
bulunuruz. Cebirsel temsil ne demek
aslında? Diyor ki x'lerle y adam gibi
diyor denklem çöz. Benim canımı sıkma
diyor. Yine gerildim. Benim gerilme
saatlerim gelmiş. Şimdi yaşlandıkça
böyle oluyor. Ara ara. Yapacağın şey şu.
Sana f(x)'i vermiş ya. FX yerine ahan da
şu cebirsel temsilini yazacaksın. Yani
diyeceksin ben a'yı burada çözeceğim ya.
Beni oraya sığdıramazsınız.
f(x) yerine -2x + 4 yazıyorum. Ü 0
diyorum ve ben bunu çözüyorum. Bunun
çözüm aralığını bulacağım. Yapacağım şey
şu. Eksi ile çarpmaktan kaçındığım için
-2x'i karşıya göndereyim de + 2x olsun
diyorum. Burası da 4. Şimdi her iki
tarafı temizinden bir 2 ile tokatlarsam
cart curt. Ne oldu? Sağ tarafta x kaldı.
Sol tarafta 4'ü 2'ye böldüm. 2 tertemiz.
2 > eş x buldum. Ya da sağdan sola
okursam x < 2 buldum aslında. Tamam mı?
Şimdi ben onu çözeyim. Hatta niye ben
onu şöyle yazmadım ki? X < 2 bulduk.
Ayıp mı canım böyle yazmak? Aynı şey.
Çözüm aralığı şu. 2'den başlıyoruz ama
daha küçüğüz. Demek ki eksi sonsuza eksi
sonsuzdan geliyorum. 2'ye kadar 2'yi de
dahil edeceğim köşeli parantezle.
Şimdi geldim Bursa'ya. Canımda bir
şeftali çektik. Kimse de demiyor hocaya
bir şeftali gönderelim. Belki mevsimi
değil diye de göndermiyor olabiliriz.
Şimdi B'ye geldim.
Şeftali ne arar? Bursa'da diyorsunuz.
GX'in X - 6 olduğunu biliyoruz. O zaman
cevirsel temsilini yazdım. X - 6 ne var?
Üç 0 var. O zaman ü0 derim. Hemen -6'yı
tokatlarım. Karşıya gönderirim. + 6
geçer. Bitti. X 6 buldum. O zaman ne
diyeceğim?
Eksi sonsuzdan 6'ya kadar 6 dahil değil.
Tertemiz çözdüm. Sıradaki gelsin. O f(x)
> g(x) demişiz. O zaman hemen sen bana
bir f(x)'i söyler misin? f(x) neydi? -2x
+ 4 yazıyorum. -2x + 4 > eşit diyorum.
Şimdi bir de g(x) patlatın bana. O da
neydi? x - 6. Hemencik x - 6 yazdım.
Şimdi eksilerle canım sıkılmasın diye şu
-2x'i karşıya göndereceğim. Yani x'in
yanına + 2x geçecek. Sol tarafta bir
+4'üm var. -6 durur mu? Hani bana hani
bana diyor. Onu da +6 olarak
gönderiyorum. Sol taraf ne oldu? 10
oldu. Çok güzel. 10 >=
3x olarak buldum. Ya da sağdan sola
okuyalım. Hani x başa gelsin. 3x <<= 10
diye de söyleyebiliriz. Herkesi şöyle
bir 3 ile tokatlayalım. 3'leri pazara
gönderdim. X < 10/3 buldum. Ben bunu
aralık olarak yazarım. küçük dediği için
belli ki sonsuzdan geliyorum. Nereye
kadar? 10/3'e kadar. Dahil mi? Dahil
tabii. Çünkü küçük eşittir demiş. Eşitti
de var. O yüzden köşelimi çaktım. Hop.
7. sorudayım. Şimdi fonksiyonu verilmiş.
Eşitsizinin çözüm aralığını fonksiyon
grafik temsilinden faydalan faydalanarak
bulunuz diyor. Oo dikkat dikkat grafik
temsil ediyor. O zaman ne yapacağız?
Kolları sıvayacağız grafik çizeceğiz.
Neyin grafiği hocam? fonksiyonunun
grafiği. Başka bir şey mi var ortada?
Şimdi gel önce bunu bir çizelim. Önce
ben bir dağıtayım mı bunu? Dağıtayım.
3'ü dağıtıyorum. Ne olacak? 3x/ 2 - 3
olacak değil mi? Çok güzel. Yani bunu
şöyle düşünebilirsin. y = 3x/ 2 - 3 gibi
de düşünebilirsin. Şimdi bana bir
fonksiyonun şey lazım. Grafiği lazım.
fonksiyonunun grafiği lazım. Dolayısıyla
hemen kendime bir koordinat sistemi
çizdim. Burada
x'e 0 vereyim. Y'yi nereden kesiyor
bulayım. X'e 0 verirsem ne olur gençler?
Burayı tak diye yutarsınız değil mi? X
gitti. E ne kaldı? Y = -3 kaldı. Demek
ki x'in 0 olduğu yerde y -3'müş. Yani
grafik ekseni y eksenini -3'te kesiyor.
Cart diye bu noktayı işaretledim. Temiz.
Şimdi bir de tersten girişelim. Y'ye 0
verip x'i bulayım. Bunun için bir şöyle
denklem yapalım. 3x/ 2 - 3. Bak y'ye 0
verdim. Gördün değil mi? -3 karşıya + 3
geçirdim. 3 = 3x/ 2. Her iki tarafı 3'e
böldüm. Burası 1. 2'yi de karşıya
şutlarsam x = 2 çıkar. Ahan da y'ye 0
verdiğimde x2'ymiş. O da şurası
x2. Tamam. Bak istersen deneyelim. X'e 2
verdiğimde ne oluyor? 2/2 1 oluyor.
1'den 1 çıkarttım. Parantezin içi 0.
Demek ki x y de 0 çıkıyor. Yani x'e 2
verirsem y yok. 0. Tamam. Şimdi ne
yapıyoruz? Bunu birleştiriyoruz. Şöyle
tak diye iki noktadan geçecek şekilde bu
arkadaşı birleştirdim. Hocam sen ne
yaptın şu an? Ne çizdin hocam? Ne çizdin
biliyor musun? y = f(x) grafiğini çizmiş
oldum. Sen şimdi ne istiyorsun benden?
İstediğin şey f(x) > 0.
fonksiyonunun 0'dan büyük olduğu yerleri
istiyorsun benden. Oralar neresi? Ben
sana tarıyayım. Hemen de tarım. Bak F
neydi? F şu Y'ydi. Y değerinin 0'dan
büyük olduğu yer ne demek? Şunun üstü
demek. asansörün zeminin üst katları
demektir. Yani şurası, şurası, şurası.
Bak buralarda hep y değerlerine git. Ne
var? Pozitif değerler var. Ama mesela
şurada y değeri nedir? Negatif bir
sayıdır. Mevzuyu çakozladık mı? O zaman
nereyi tarıyorum? İşte tam olarak şu
kısmı tarıyorum. Tamam. Bir de bunu
tabii şıklık olsun. Çözüm aralığı olarak
da yazalım. Bak, x'in 2den büyük olduğu
yerlerde neymişiz biz? Y değerimiz. Yani
fonksiyonumuz pozitifmiş. Dolayısıyla da
çözüm aralığımızı bu şekilde, çözüm
aralığını da bul demiş ya. Çünkü çözüm
aralığını da 2'ye ve sonsuza şeklinde
aralık olarak yazabiliriz. Çünkü aralık
ayındayız. Kasım ayında çekiyor olsaydım
ben burada farklı çözüm yapardım. Ocak
ayında çekiyor olsaydım bambaşka şeyler.
7. soru bitti. Şimdi o zaman geliyorum.
Geliyorum babalara. 8 ve 9. sorudu.
Soruda aşırtlı blackboard yapacağız.
Sert sorular. Dolayısıyla eğer eee
kalpten bir sorununuz varsa gerekli
işlemleri yapıp öyle ilerleyin. Tamam
mı? Babalara geldik. Zor değil ha.
Sadece bir tık daha farklı. Gördüğün
gibi zaten biz 8. soruyu yazdık. 4 tane
şıkkı var.
Şimdi
60 cm uzunluğunda dikilip sabit hızla
uzayan bir fidankonun boyu 2. yılın
sonunda 90'a ulaşmış. Tak diye 90'a
ulaşıyor. Bu fidanın zamana yani yıldan
bahsediyoruz bağlı olarak boyunu
gösteren fonksiyon fonksiyonuymuş.
Buna göre soruları cevaplayacağız. Bir
kere bu fonksiyonun cebirsel temsilini
yazınız. Ben seninle bunu 8. sınıfta çok
fazla çözdüm. Fonksiyon demedik o zaman.
Doğrusal denklem dedik. Hep ne yaptık?
Taksiciye örnek verdik. Ne demiştik?
Taksinin ücreti taksiye ödeyeceğim ücret
Y dedim. Bak örneğimiz buydu. İşte bu
ücret demişti ki taksinin kapının
kapısının koluna değdiğinde bir açılış
ücreti var. Atıyorum 20 lira 20 + her
gittiğim kilometre için 5 lira yazıyorsa
5x. Buradaki x de kilometre demiştik.
İşte bu da ödeyeceğimiz TL olarak para
demiştik. Bunları çözdük biz seninle.
Ufaktan bir tekrar etmek istiyorsan 8.
sınıf doğrusal denklemler, partikül,
matematik yazarak izleyebilirsin. Bence
izlemeni de tavsiye ederim. Şimdi
yapacağım şey şu. O zaman y =
yazmayacağım artık çünkü 9. sınıfı ben
liseli oldum. Bayağı fonksiyon filan
biliyorum. Dolayısıyla
f(x) yazacağım. f(x) = diyeceğim.
Bu f(x) nedir? boydur. Tamam mı? Bu
fidanın boyu. FX çünkü bağımlı değişken
y bu arkadaşımız. Y neye bağlı? İşte
yıllara bağlı. Sen bana 5 yılı
soruyorsan 5 yıl sonrasını bulurum. 10
yıl sonra 10 yıl sonrası daha da uzar.
Yıla bağlı olarak değişiyor. O yüzden
bağımlı arkadaşımız bu. Peki nereden
başlıyor? Sen buna hiçbir şey yapmasan
bu arkadaşın zaten boyu 60 cm. Ama bu
uzuyor tabii yerinde de durmuyor. Ne
yapmış bak yılda 90'a ulaşmış. Hemen
şöyle bir ufak 1. sınıf işlemleri
yapalım. 90'a ulaşmış. E ilk boyu 60'tı.
Demek ki 30 cm uzamış. Kaç yılda uzamış?
2 yılda. O zaman bunu 2'ye bölersem 1
yılda 15 cm uzar. Demek ki 60'ın üstüne
15 x x diyeceğim. Hemen kontrol
ediyoruz. 2. yılda 90 oluyordu. Bakalım.
X yerine 2 yazdığımda çünkü buradaki x
zamandır. Bak yıl bağımsız değişkenim.
Fidanın boyu da yıla bağlı bağımlı
değişken. Şimdi buradaki zaman sen
buraya kalkıp 2 yazarsan 15 x 2'den
burası 30 olur. E bir de başında 60'ım
vardı. 60 30 topladım 90. Oldu mu?
Olacak tabii lan. Biz bunun için
yıllarca okul okuduk. Şimdi gelelim
grafik temsiline. Bunu çizittireceğiz.
Çok basit. Hiç stres yapma. Sadece
yapacağın şey iki tane düz çizik atmak.
Şöyle grafiğin daha doğrusu koordinat
sistemini çiz. Şuralar y ekseni
biliyorsun. Buralar da x. X neydi? Yıl
yani zaman. Y neydi? Boy. Yani
santimetre cinsinden. Tamam. Şimdi 1ci
yılım var, 2inci yılım var. Fakat bir de
0 yılım var. Yani nokta atış başlangıç
noktası. Bu kardeşimiz nereden başlıyor?
60'tan. O zaman Y zaten hiçbir şey
yapmasan 60'tan başlayacak. Ondan sonra
bu böyle uzaya uzaya gidecek değil mi?
Fakat bu uzadığında 1ci yıla geldiğinde
karşıl şöyle büyüt ya. 1ci yıla
geldiğinde karşılığında ne göreceksin?
Bir 15 cm uzayacak. 75. Çünkü her yıl 15
uzadığını bulmuştum. 2inci yıla
geldiğinde de ne göreceğiz? Karşısında
90'ı göreceğiz. Bak 75'ten bir 15 daha
uzadım. Mevzu bu. Grafik temsilinde
çizittirdim. Şimdi soru diyor ki, "Kaç
yıl sonra o zaman 135 olur?" Ney? O 135
olan fonksiyonu. Yani benim f(x)
fonksiyonumda
şu f(x)'in yani y değerinin 135 olduğu
yılı soruyor. 135 olduğu x'i soruyor.
Yani hemen denklemi kurar patır kütür
çözerim. 135 = 60 + 15x
60'ı buraya eksi gönderdim. Ne çıkıyor?
75 mi kalıyor? 135'ten 60 çıktı. Bak 75
değilse sizden bilirim ha. 75'tir. 15x.
Her iki tarafı da 15'e böldüğümde
tak 15'ler pazara gitti. X e= buradan da
5 kaldı. Demek ki 5 yıl sonunda ben 135
cm olacağını biliyorum. Tamam. Şimdi
diğer sorum. Kaç yıl sonra 300'ü geçer?
Kim geçer? f(x) y değeri. Ne zaman 300'ü
geçer diyor. Yani kuracağım şey şu. f(x)
> 300.
Bunu yazacağım. E f(x)'in cebirsel
temsilini biliyorum ki ben. f(x)'in
cebirsel temsilini aa yukarıda yazdım.
Yani 60 + 15x
> 300. Ben bunu çözeceğim. Hemen
başlıyorum. Şimdi 60'ı şöyle sağ tarafa
sıpıtalım. 15x > 300'den 60 çıktı 240.
Şimdi her ikisi tarafı da neye
böleceğim? 15'e böleceğim ki x'i yalnız
bulayım. Tenh da kıstırayım. 240'ı 15'e
böl bölebilirsen inşallah tam bölünür
diyerek niyet ediyorum. Ve başlıyorum.
Şimdi burada 8 desem yer misin?
Yemezsin. Yavaş. Bir kere var oğlum. Kim
dedi lan? 8 çıksın dışarı. 1 kere 15
çıkarttım 9. 9da 15 yok. 0a indirdim.
90'da 6 kere var değil mi? 33 6 kere
var. O zaman her iki tarafı 15'e
böldüğümde x > 6'yı buluyorum. Peki ne
diyeceğim? Kaç yıl sonra 300'ü geçer? 6
yıl sonra geçemez. 6 yıl sonra 300 olur.
O zaman ne diyeceğim? 7 yıl sonra
diyeceğim. Anlaştık mı? Tabii. Tabii.
Benim gibi işlem hatası yapmayacaksınız.
Burası 16'ydı. Oğlum kim 6 dedi?
Çıldıracağım ya. 16'dan büyük 17
diyeceğiz. Bir 7 deyince orayı bir
durdurdum. Bir kontrol ettim lan nereden
çıktı 7 diye. 17 17 Tamam sakin. X'i
burada 240'ı 15'e böldüğümüzde 16 çıktı.
Ama 16'dan büyük olacağız diye ne dedik?
17 yıl sonra dedik. Şimdi aynısının
laciv verdi. Bir sorum daha var. Last
question diyoruz. Tamam. Olaya noktayı
koyacağız. A ve B tabletlerimiz var. Gid
tabletlerin bataryaları tam doluymuş. Ne
güzel. İnsanların çalışan, donmayan
tabletleri var. İken tabletler
kullanılmaya başlanmış ve tabletler
şarjları bitene kadar kullanılmaya devam
edilmiş. Tabletlerin birim zamanda
harcadıkları şarj miktarları eşitmiş.
Güzel. A ve B tabletlerinde kalan şarj
miktarları zamana bağlı olarak sırasıyla
uygun aralıklarda tanımlı fg
fonksiyonlarıyile ifade edilmiş.
F'ten başlayalım. Aha dur bir saniye.
Lan telefonları kapatın diyorum size ya.
Tamam kapattık telefonları. Şimdi burada
yapacağım şey ne? Ha, f ile g'yi
anlatıyordum. Şimdi bak, bu fonksiyonu
sırasıyla demişiz, değil mi? Eee,
sırasıyla demişiz. Tamam. A tabletinin
fonksiyonu yani A tabletinin kalan şarj
miktarı. Mevzu bu. Kalan şarj miktarını
gösteriyormuş fonksiyonlar. Diğeri de B
tabletinin. Şimdi bana diyor ki A ve B
marka tabletlerde başlangıçtaki şarj
kaçtır? Diyor. Bak, işlem yapanın kalemi
kırılsın.
işlemsiz çözeceğiz. Nasıl hocam? Sen
münecip misin? Nasıl? Zihinden mi?
Hayır. Buradaki FX nereden başlıyor?
7,2'den. O zaman A marka tabletin şarjı
7,2'dir başlangıçta. Çünkü fonksiyon
bana kalanı söylüyor.
Demek ki en başta bunun 7.2'si var. Her
saatte 06 düşüyor. En son sıfırlanacak
bir yerde. Anladık mı mevzuyu? 7.2.
Şimdi o zaman B'yi sen söyle. B
tabletinin başlangıçtaki şarjı tabii ki
de 5,4'tür.
Tertemiz. Kılçıksız çözdüm. 2inci soru.
Birer saatte harcadıkları şarj
miktarları diyor ya. Ben az önce sana
taksi örneğini verdim ya. Ne demiştim? y
= işte taksi başlangıçta 20 lira alıyor.
Sonra da kilometre başı ne alıyorsa x'in
başına onu yazıyoruz demiştim. Yani
birim zamandaki artışı ya da azalışı
x'in başına yazıyoruz. O zaman burada
x'in başında yazanlar belli. 06 diğeri
de 02. Yine işlemsiz çözüyorum.
O zaman A marka tablet için 1 saatte 06
tükettiğini söyleyebilirim. Bak 1 saatte
harcadıklarını sormuş. Kalanı sormamış.
Fonksiyonda niye yerine yazmadın hocam
ya? Niye yazayım? Fonksiyon bana kalan
şarjı söyler ama ben bunun bir saatte
tabletin yediği şarjı zaten şurada
görüyorum. B tabletinin şarjı için B 0.2
diyeceğim. Geçeceğim. Tertemiz akıyor
sorular. Şimdi tamamen tükeneceği zamanı
bulalım. İşte şimdi gel. Önce A'dan
başlıyorum. A için fonksiyonumuz F. f(x)
= 7,2 x özür dilerim 7,2 - 0,6x.
Ne istiyorum? Şarjın tamamen tükenmesini
istiyorum. Yani kalanın
0 olmasını istiyorum. Bu da nedir?
fonksiyonun 0 olmasını istiyorum
demektir. Yani şuranın 0 olmasını
istiyorum. Anlaştık mı? O zaman 0'a
eşitlerim. Ben bu denklemi pataküte
çözerim. Hemen şu 06'yı karşıya atacağım
ki artılı olsun. Yani 06x = 7,2. Her iki
tarafı 10'la çarpayım. Şu virgüller
canımı çok sıktı. Şimdi x'i bulabilirim.
72'yi 6'ya böl ne olacak? 12. A tableti
12 saat gidiyormuş. Tamam mı? Bu yarım
elmalardan herhalde. Şimdi diğerine
bakalım. Tamam mı? Orada da G
fonksiyonumuz var. GX fonksiyonu e= 54 -
02x.
Burada da g'nin sıfırlanmasını
istiyoruz. Hemen 0 e= diyerek denklemi
tekrar yazdım. Eksili kardeşimizi bu
tarafa alıyorum ki artılı olsun. 0x =
5.4. Her iki tarafı yine virgüllerden
kurtulmak için 10'la çarptım ki bunu
yapabilirim.
2x 54 mü? O zaman x kaç çıkıyor? 27.
Güzel. Bu kardeşimiz B marka tablette 27
saat akıyormuş. Akıyor. Bu acaba
hangisi? Bu da armutlardan mı? Şimdi son
sorum. Bunların eşit olacağı zamanı bul
diyor. Neyin eşit olacağı? tabletlerin
şarjlarının yani kalan şarjlarının
ikisinin de eşit olacağı yer. Mesela
%60'a %60 kaldı ikisinde de. Kalanı
soruyor bana. Kalanı veren kimdi?
Fonksiyonların kendisiydi.
O yüzden ne yapacağım? f(x) = g(x)
isteyeceğim. Bana öyle bir x ver ki
ikisi eşit olsun. Dolayısıyla bunların
cebirsel temsillerini alıyorum. Pataküte
çözüyorum. f(x) neydi?
7,2 - 06x'ti.
Eşitleyeceğim. Diğerinin kalanı g
fonksiyonunda 5.4 - 0.2x.
Şimdi 5.4'ü 7.2'nin yanına eksi
atacağım. 0,6'yı da diğer tarafa artı
atacağım. Bir daha yazıyorum. Yaklaş.
Şimdi 7,2
-5,4
= 06 + geldi. 06 yani pozitif geldi. 06x
02x'ten
02xi çıkaracağım. Sağ taraf 0 4x değil
mi? Orada bir çok cereyan yok. Orayı
hallettik. 72'den 5.4'ü çıkaracağım.
Hadi bu sefer kendimi ondalıktan
kurtarmadım. Risk alıyorum. İşte hayatta
alacağın en büyük risk bu olsun. Şimdi
[kahkaha]
burada da 8 6 kaldı. 1 mi? 1.8 Tamam.
Ondalıklarla benim mesaim buraya kadar.
Bundan sonra çıldırırım. Hemen her iki
tarafı 10'la çarpıyorum. 18 = 10'la
çarptım 4x. Şimdi 18'i de 4'e böldüğümde
zaten sağdaki 4'ler gitti. Amacımız oydu
zaten. X'i yalnız bıraktık. X'i ne
bulacağız şimdi? Hadi söyle. 18'i 4'e
bölün. Kaç çıkıyor? 4 kere 4 16 mı? Çat
çut. Hop hop 2 hop. Bir 0 1 virgül. Hop
5. 4,5 saat sonra iki tabletinde kalan
şarjları aynı olur. Tamam der. Ben de bu
dersi
bitiririm. Yeter ya. Yorulduk. Boğaz 36
dakikadır. Konuş konuş konuş konuş. Hiç
de demiyorsunuz ki hocaya bir destek
atalım, bir yardım edelim, bir like, bir
abonelik bile bizim şarjımızı yükseltir.
Oradan hesap edebilirsiniz. Evet 9.
sınıflar. Bu dersi burada noktaladım.
Önümüzdeki derste yine gelene kadar ne
yapıyorsun? Ödevlerini yapmayı
unutmuyorsun. Çözüm videolarından da
faydalanabilirsin. Şahane sorularım var.
Kitabı dediğim gibi hala edinmediysen
bence geç kalmadın. Yarı yıl tatili de
geliyor. Orada da tokatlarsın. Bu
kardeşimiz kaç sayfa biliyor musun?
Soranlar oluyor. 280 sayfaymış. Yani
dediğim gibi baştan tuğla yapmaya hani
inşaat işine girelim dedik. Sonra baktık
biz eğitimciyiz. Oğlum bu olmaz deyip
tuğlayı kitaba dönüş. Öyle kalın, öyle
de bol soru var içinde. Her dersin
sonunda yazılı örnekleri de var
biliyorsun. Dolayısıyla şu an 9. sınıfta
okula yardımcı ek bir kaynak alayım.
Özel derslerle devam edeyim. Bak bu
birebir derstir. Kitabı birlikte
işliyoruz. Ondan sonra da ödevlerini
yapacaksın. 9. sınıfı tas tamam
halledeceksin. Derdimiz bu. 10. sınıfa
sağlam geçelim. Çünkü 10. sınıf ders
videolarından da anlamışsındır. Şu an 35
ders falan çektik 10. sınıflara. Çünkü
çok yoğun. Yetişemiyoruz. Çok fazla.
Oraya geldiğinde işte 9'dan bir şeyin
kalmaması lazım. 9'u çok iyi halledersen
o 10. sınıfta pat pat devam edeceksin.
Hatırlatmamı yapayım. Sonra siz Melih
hoca dediydi dersiniz. Bir sonraki ders
o zaman yeniden görüşünceye dek
kendinize çok iyi bakın ve matematikle
kalın. Hoşça kalın.